deux personnes responsables mais sur
itrafik des gens responsables soient
tenus responsables
maintenant qu'on sait que monsieur novak
savez on est capable de conclure que
monsieur car vous savez j'ai demandé m
sur ta fille de rembourser les
contribuables
ça commence à être de moins en moins
crédible alors on l'a vu en début de
bulletins les témoignage au procès de
mac d'office celui de son ancien bras
droit n'a d'abord maintenant de son
ancien avocat benjamenta rennes continue
de miner la campagne électorale des
conservateurs d'achat et ce soir à
halifax daniel et à ottawa mme chez lui
et à montréal bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoir
donc on apprend que novak le chef de
cabinet actuel qui l'accompagnent dans
sa campagne de stephen harper aurait été
au courant du remboursement de 90 mille
dollars fait par nigel wright à mike
duffy monsieur rappeur on vient
d'entendre a réitéré sa confiance envers
nous et novak mais michel quand même ça
change un peu la donne monsieur novak va
t-il rester ou doit-il partir
sinovac est au centre du scénario qu'on
nous raconte depuis le début de la
campagne c'est à dire que novak n'était
pas à la réunion où on doit discuter du
fameux 98 dollars et ça c'est la preuve
qu'on peut ne sais pas parce que il est
évident de nous hisse tout les
conservateurs qui qui en parlent que si
novak l'avait su elle aurait dit à son
patron serait pas pu être autrement
on l'a maintenant on sait que monsieur
novak le savez il ya trois possibilités
ou bien monsieur rapport savait et il
fait partie depuis le début de cette
tentative de camouflage ou bien monsieur
novak a menti à son premier ministre
quelqu'un il faut qu'ils soient
congédiés demain matin ou bien donc je
vous ai franchement que je crois pas la
troisième hypothèse ces veinards porte
une sorte de gerald tremblay là qui sait
pas ce qui se passe dans son paquet dans
son propre bureau
j'ai beaucoup de misère
recevoir daniel écouter un nom renault
vague ne va pas partir il va rester là
parce que c'est un fidèle et parce que
s'ils venaient à un peu les indiens et
parce que surtout il reste six jours de
procès de fait avant l'ajournement du
procès ce jusqu'après les élections donc
encore une semaine de torture et après
il restera cette semaine à stephen rapp
eux pour tenter de reprendre le contrôle
reprendre le dessus imposer ses idées
ses projets ses thèmes et ses terrains
parce que depuis le début de la campagne
depuis le début du procès de fait n'a
j'aurai des compagnies chaque jour six
venant peu à l'air tendu il a l'air
fâché
on sent toujours qu'il est sur le point
d'exploser ça ne peut pas durer comme ça
même dans son entourage et plus ou moins
éloigné dans sa base des gens qui
commencent à s'inquiéter sérieusement il
faut que le premier ministre peut
effectuer un virage radical sinon il
sera trop tard tâche alors que petit
faire parce que c'est vous qui nous
expliquer très clairement la semaine
dernière le calcul politique daniel en
parler c'était de laisser passer la
tempête et que ce serait oublier au
moins dans le 19 octobre
mais là est ce que ça risque pas de
durer on a encore 60 jours qui restent
dans cette campagne c'est long c'est
deux mois ces deux campagnes
traditionnelles presque alors beaucoup
de choses peuvent arriver je pense
monsieur à peu ne va pas congédier
monsieur novak parce que ce serait en
fait dans un sens pour pour quelle
raison une admission que monsieur novak
aurait dû nuit d'hier parce que monsieur
repris mais rien qui ne lui a pas dit
qu'il y avait un chèque
écoutez monsieur novak répondait aussi à
monsieur rice et son patron et monsieur
wright si c'est possible que monsieur
novak ne peut dire je n'ai rien dit non
plus et on peut prendre le premier
ministre à son mot ou l'on peut dire que
non il m'emmenait à la fin de la journée
conseiller mais si novak ça résoudrait
pas le problème
attendre que d'autres événements
d'autres des boys d'autres questions se
soulève et complète enterrer cette
affaire un peu je pense que c'est ça la
stratégie que les conservateurs vont
adopter
michel est ce que ça ne vient pas risqué
quand même pour monsieur rapport oui ça
devient risqué parce que les questions
d'éthique ont pas tendance à s'en aller
aussi facilement que les autres comme
une tâche à 100
ça ne s'efface pas facilement alors le
problème oui vendredi prochain pas
demain l'autre vendredi le procès sera
journée jusqu'au mois de novembre mais
on va continuer par de parler de cette
affaire là et la sphère de fait qui a
fait beaucoup couler d'encre va rester
dans le paysage elle ne s'effacera pas
même si on est en campagne électorale
même s'il reste 60 jours alors c'est
compliqué bon monsieur harper il va
falloir trouver un autre scénario aussi
le scénario autrefois il monsieur novak
était central là dedans les simpson au
bancomat hier son premier ministre l'a
expliqué quelque chose ici monsieur noah
qui a comme disparus d'ailleurs dans
cette campagne 8h à oui j'allais dire le
seul engagement que ça fait le seul
problème c'est vraiment pour la base
conservatrice les gens qui votent npd ou
libérale et qui croient que monsieur
harper manque de toute façon sur plein
de choses ça fait rien ça change pas
leurs idées que si messieurs novak a dit
la vérité ou non
la grande question c'est la base
conservatrice et c'est là où monsieur
harper est en danger il peut pas se
permettre de perdre mais on a besoin
absolument
et ces gens là doivent être convaincus
il ya soixante jours pour les rassurer
que même s'ils ne sont pas contents
présentement sur des questions de
criminalité etc
les conservateurs c'est le meilleur
choix parce que nous sommes sept
semaines l'américain des conservateurs
des militants conservateurs qui sont
vraiment inquiet on le sent il y avait
ce sondage plus tôt cette semaine vous
l'avez peut-être dû qui disait bon temps
2 % seulement des canadiens suivent le
projet d'eau fait des autres s'en fout
éperdument
sauf que sur les 32 % il ya 11 % de
conservateur pur et dur qui commence à
se poser de très sérieuses questions
et c'est ces gens là dont parle d'achats
que monsieur râpeux a besoin de rassurer
parce que sa base on s'entend pour dire
on l'a déjà dit sur cette tribune et dit
autour de 30 % de gens qui ne voteront
jamais pour les autres partis ce sont
des conservateurs mais peuvent décider
de rester à la maison ils peuvent
décider tout et c'est venu un peu ça
c'est fait monsieur un peu doit
maintenant rattraper ces gens là les
ramener au parti remonter à 30 % et pour
gagner il a besoin de quoi 35,8 la
dernière fois pour avec une majorité
longuet besoin de chercher un autre
saint constant et c'est là où ça va être
extrêmement difficile parce que je
rejoins michel là-dessus compter sur les
partis d'opposition et dans les débats
télévisés et dans la pub
is it était divisée j'ai déjà vu une
publicité libéral aujourd'hui vous allez
voir beaucoup la face de mme aïda fait
le nahd joe wright de rénova cas de
benjamin beilman de tous ces gens là
pour rappeler aux gens
il s'est passé des choses on veut pas
l'oublier même s'il reste deux mois de
campagne
alors aujourd'hui il y avait sept 7 pro
ses deux filles qui se continue il y
avait aussi un sondage qui n'est pas
très bon pour monsieur enfin sondages au
québec on en parlait tout à l'heure donc
le npd 13 en avance sur six autres
adversaires au québec michel je vois que
vous avez l'air sceptique je sais c'est
un sondage d'été mais quand même
est-ce que c'est pas difficile pour
monsieur mulcair qui se retrouve très
haut
peut-être un peu vite il détruit dans la
chanson d'âge là il est nettement trop
de moi je ne crois pas que 47% alors les
probablement un peu plus que ça cela dit
il est déjà il est déjà celui qui est
l'objet de toutes les attaques
il faut pas se le cacher il est leader
de la course ça le confirme donc il va
être celui qu'on va attaquer cela dit il
ya deux choses un sondage de damart site
c'est vraiment 47 % au québec ça veut
dire qu'il faut pas croire les sondages
du reste du canada parce qu'il doit être
beaucoup plus bas que ça c'est pour ça
que je vous dis que je pense trop sûr
que de ce sondage la sté sondage d'été
d'autre part le sondage fait très mal
un monsieur un peu parce qu'il va avoir
des musées a gardé les sièges qui au
québec et beaucoup à monsieur trudeau
parce que monsieur trudeau doit gagner
au québec
ça fait partie du mandat qu'il est allé
chercher deux de son parti et c'est pas
avec moins de 20% des voix convivial fin
mais surtout un shérif francophone c'est
encore plus ici 13%
daniel way je suis d'accord avec michel
moi aussi j'ai des difficultés avec ce
sondage un écart de 11 % dans une si
courte période de temps t l'émirat qui
arrive à cet être le sondage ou tout à
coup beaucoup les gens allaient dans la
même direction
ou comme dit michel tout le monde est en
vacances et puis bon mais il ya eu des
problèmes ya eu beaucoup de ratés avec
les sondages ces deux dernières années
penser à l'économie britannique pense à
l'alberta je n'enlève rien à crocs ce
sont des professionnels
sauf que comme michel j'ai des réserves
cela étant dit moi je suis pas convaincu
qu'il faut encore immédiatement éliminé
le bloc québécois attendons voir le
sondage
attendons voir les débats
don de voir les prochains sondages est
ce que la cote de mulcair va se
maintenir à ce niveau là s il y aura une
tendance on pensait lui avoir fait très
mal avec le dossier du pipeline de
l'énergie de l'ess sur lequel le bloc
québécois tu as très fort ça n'a pas
l'air de toucher les québécois jérémy
nations non plus non plus je pense pas
non c'était c'était une anecdote en
passant je pense que les québécois
revient toujours à la même question est
ce qu'on veut oui ou non continuer avec
stephen harper et ceux qui ne veulent
pas continuer avec s'ils veulent qu'on
peut se tourner vers le npd et non pas
vers le bloc québécois ne va pas fort on
sent sur le terrain que les gens
m'aiment au chalet beaucoup de
souverainistes très ouvert qui disent
non à cette année on se débarrasse de
hauteur ça veut dire voter npd
c'est la grande question ce n'est plus
la tis que la souveraineté passe par le
bloc québécois je pense que les gens
réalisent que le ch'ti la sauvette est
toujours ça passerait si sa jeunesse à
passer par le québec mais deuxièmement
que c'est moins important de faire
représenter le québec avec un parti
différent que de effectivement faire
donner la porte à monsieur pour les gens
au québec qui pensent que de voir une
autre option alors c'est ça qui est
vraiment je pousse le vote du npd et qui
écrase un peu le vote du bloc
moi je vois mal comment ça va changer et
même si monsieur mulcair a dit qu'il
aime madame thatcher que c'est une
nouvelle surprise pour moi en tout cas
écoute je voulais me suis fait pas
autant de balles que ça parce que les
québécois le connaissais comme un
libéral provincial c'est pas un grand
secret qui n'était pas une énorme
socialiste alors c'est plus ces
messieurs un peu qu'ils représentent ces
jours même quand on a choisi comme chef
et rappelez-vous la vieille garde du bas
du parti néo-démocrate thomas mulcair
s'est pas vraiment un des nôtres c'est
plus du centre centre droit il n'est pas
ou si gauchistes qu'on veut thomas
mulcair n'en fait pas de mystère il a
ramené le parti du nouveau parti
démocratique au centre c'est là où il
doit gouverner comme tony blair la femme
grande bretagne comme raï romane ou la
sphère sociale showman garrido khomeiny
au manitoba
tous les gouvernements de gauche qui ont
réussi à gouverner au centre et même un
peu au centre droit c'était vrai pour
tony blair
assuré de faire savoir à ses yeux des
électeurs qui ont pris aux socialistes
l'odeur n'est pas si pire que ça
manquait alors mais au canada anglais on
se dit ça parce que c'est effectivement
les les électeurs de gauche ont pas ils
vont pas aller à monsieur trudeau et les
électeurs de libéro mou que les lampes
et des doigts courtoise et ils vont
regarder sa laideur peut-être les
festivals bon j'ai une dernière question
on va y aller rapidement c'est sûr
kathleen wynne parce que quand même il
faut parler de ce qui se passe en
ontario catherine qui fait très très
ouvertement campagne pour justin trudeau
de façon très partisane et là la
question se pose est-ce que ça crée un
malaise parce que s'il perd justin
trudeau qu'est ce qui va arriver à
l'ontario quelle sorte de voile ontario
va voir après une élection comme celle
là michel rapidement il est difficile de
quand on est élu le quand la campagne
est finie de ne pas travailler que le
premier ministre de l'ontario quand on
est le premier ministre du canada
on peut l'aimer ou pas le dos mais ça
c'est une autre histoire mais une fois
l'élection passée il va nécessairement y
avoir des ponts qui vont être jetés de
part et d'autre
donc c'est pas si difficile pour être au
mieux une escale à zeitoun pas
travailler avec vos amis ministres
l'ontario mais s'il venait à peu ne le
faisais pas de toute façon alors elle
pas grand chose à terre de madame
mélanie il a pris tant de temps à la
rencontre et ça change pas les grand
chose mais ça démontre un peu le malaise
qu'est madame wind et couvrant vers lui
je pense et ça peut être risqué non
comme stratégiques en main mais
peut-être mais je pense pas que vous
vraiment libéral en thériault attend
beaucoup ils ont ils ont ils préfèrent
je pense une relation adversaires avec
ottawa aussi pour améliorer leurs bases
en ontario elle aussi à la prochaine
élection jean rouge à québec bleus à
tahoua vice versa de saint-marcel otayo
aussi bon alors troisième semaine de
campagne qui s'achève nous en reste deux
mois encore si tu as le temps de suivre
ça de près de 3 des heures de plaisir
bizarre mais avec vous c'est quand même
toujours intéressant merci